peu
l'autobus qu'on croyait attaché à la
route a pris une nouvelle forme
il s'est fait volant et c'est en
normandie qu'il est né chaque jour de
cet ep un service d'hélicoptères
assurera le transport des voyageurs deux
camps au havre en pesant diverses halde
sur le parcours
le tout en 40 minutes gros avantage
lorsqu'on sait que le parcours par route
nécessite quatre heures les 15 passagers
de la banane volante gagneront donc un
temps qu'on estime parfois presque mais
le plus gros avantage et surtout le plus
apprécié sera de découvrir d'un point de
vue inhabituel le charme de la normandie
et d'ouvrir une nouvelle route au
touriste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]